[Music]
[Laughter]
we just throw it on them and they're
just like trying to jump in
that's the best part that is the best so
we got sham
booty back today i know
some time no secret i felt offended
that's okay we're here now
i don't think i've seen you in like
three years yeah it's been years
yeah i've seen you more recently yeah i
saw you recently but it's been here
since you were here
yeah yeah and i saw you hella recently
yeah your house
yeah exactly it's just you really yeah
that's really what's happening
joe's the problem i'm always out of time
i'm trying to avoid joe yeah
i'm always out of town you had a baby
yeah i didn't have a baby
and had a baby congrats that's crazy i
know
it's awesome you know what i found that
all the advice that i got that like
say goodbye to freedom say goodbye to
joy say goodbye to
sex that hasn't been true the sex part
kind of i can kind of see that a little
bit
because you're tired right it's like you
just don't there's no time
that's the thing yeah by the time that
the baby goes to bed at like 11 it's a
rock and roll baby
yeah like she's like we're up like she's
if we're up she's up
yeah and then we have somebody who comes
and helps in the day so that person
leaves at five
why can't they stay till eleven that
would yeah
where are you at or family to help yeah
so the person who comes and helps is my
husband's brother
okay so her uncle is like here there
during the day to like help us
out so we can still work but then that
would mean between like five
and 11 she has to nap so that we can
have time for sex
yeah that's just scheduled sex well we
would it can't because sometimes she
doesn't like she's not asleep
or somebody like you have some work to
do because also like that's your times
like grind so
oh [ __ ] it should actually make me
hornier
because because you're so stressed out
and you need to get it out of your
system well you know when you first move
in with somebody it's like the over
access to sex almost makes it unsexy
yeah yeah pandemic sex
yeah yeah yeah yeah now that we only
have specific times it should actually
make it more rushed
but but it's not like that because your
mind's on other things because you're so
busy and then you can't focus
you can't focus on getting horny yeah
yeah that's why you need to put in your
calendar and invite your husband horny
time get horny email and be like
time for penetration or what's up what
are we doing and then you send the
invite yeah
except yes no maybe yeah yeah and then
maybe a different time
yeah sexy idea guys that was a very sexy
idea
that's a very sexy one that's the [ __ ]
we have zero sex
but we love it but we love that we love
the planning of it that's what we're
into
if you put it on the calendar as
spontaneous sex at 3 p.m it is more
spontaneous but then you show up
yeah then you show up like 15 minutes
late and be like oh i thought you were
showing up but you know what though
because you know how you get a calendar
reminder like half an hour before
yeah that's kind of hot yeah like you
get a little pop-up you're like oh like
i'm not now mom and it's like get to
[ __ ] in 30 minutes and you're like oh
wow you get a heat pad right on the
microwave and then warmer [ __ ] up so
it's like i'm just getting warm is that
a technique is that something that
people do
that's what chicks do yeah that's what
say that's what they do
is it that thing that rubber thing when
the water
thing when you're sick hit the water
bladder
yeah you play the microwave for two
minutes
you don't speak for all women i think
that's what they mostly do
i do they don't i've never heard that
before i heard a lot of stuff i've not
heard that and i love that the fact that
it's too hot for your hands but just
right
by the time it gets there it's good to
go yeah
it's a process
it's the residual heat that's like what
is the internal temperature of the
vagina
i'm going to say 98 degrees wouldn't it
would it be higher that's pretty good it
feels higher than the rest of the body i
think it would be higher
yeah oh yeah when i'm down there buddy
hey come on
i think it's how homeostasis works i
think it's one temperature all around
i could be incorrect i don't know if the
heart is like the lava like it's the
hardest part of the body i think we're
all is 98.6 19. not when you put glove
warmers in there
97. do you want to look up oh yeah what
is the temperature vagina during sex
98.6
i got to do it with the friction it's
not turning on fire
i guess not oh i knew i got it hotter
than that
then how come my fingertips feel colder
than my forehead
see you know we have a copious amount of
people with penises here i'd like to ask
this question
yes please ask away have you noticed a
difference i mean not in terms of smell
not in terms of likability
but in actual vaginas that you've
entered
different temperature yeah well not
temperature but like
feeling yeah for sure different feeling
yeah like
some feel i guess tighter
yeah tighter but not always a good thing
some come with more complaints different
[ __ ]
that's what he recognizes the most it's
it's different shapes for for sure
different shapes for sure i could tell
that like it's not the same it's like a
you sometimes
yeah that's weird it feels different
inside for sure i
i mean i can't see what's going on in
there but
i can tell the difference yeah so if the
person you're having sex with right now
there was three vaginas lined up and
you're blindfolded
and you could just stick it in each one
you would know which one
probably not i'd have to try it i'd have
to try this i could try too yeah
and if they really want to confuse me
have like three mouths too
he's like whoa what's that i'm
always the same either like how i feel
that's true like sometimes you're harder
to softer some days you're a rock star
or
something
sometimes i'm more sensitive and
sometimes i'm because you're eroding
less feeling
i'm not talking about performance it's
literally just once you go in
it feels different fit like putting on a
shoe yeah uh
yeah like as far as for me i think so
yeah i think so
yeah i think there's a difference i
don't know if i could and i don't know
if i can pick
like out of a lineup if i was
blindfolded but i
unless they're drastically different
maybe i don't know i can't i have to say
i can't tell the difference i can tell
i think like all the context that goes
with sex like the
visual knowing the other person the
conversation you've had
leading up to the sex all that changes
the way it feels but i think
just the fact that the penis going in
and like
feeling that i feel like it's very
isolated and some girls can kegel harder
than others
that is true not all kegels are made the
same
my main i guess like tell is
i don't know if you guys over like if
you go through a
marathon of it you it it's it starts to
hurt
or like it's more sensitive right yeah
and it's kind of like oh that shit's
like sensitive to the touch
and then so that's what you're saying
no like like okay like when you [ __ ]
like multiple
times a day yeah like or like during the
week if you just
in a new thing you're so excited you
don't even want to [ __ ] anymore but
you're just
[ __ ] right and then like the skin
around the head feels more raw i don't
know if that's the
right way to describe it but it feels
more sensitive and it hurts actually i
really thought about it
like if you come like even like three
times in a day then it's really like
yeah i don't want to do it anymore yeah
i'm like we're doing it this is like
that's when i can tell the real
difference because like if
the girl is more loose and wet it feels
better because it's not so much friction
but then if she's
super tight and not as wet it hurts
this book that i was reading said that
there's no such thing as a bomb ass
[ __ ]
so people should stop saying that being
like i have this bomb ass [ __ ] they're
like
men can't tell the difference it's all
the exact same your [ __ ] is not
what makes you a rock star yeah but
maybe there is there such thing as a
bomb ass [ __ ] where you're like that
was
like with the person just not doing it
the actual
i feel like what you said like what you
said you probably i think i don't think
any of us can tell the difference really
uh
not being a [ __ ] i'm being honest i
think that my wife is like the tightest
one that i've had
sorry yeah that's pretty sick you
haven't had my wife
what a year
showed you steve and i didn't know that
until i got with her particularly like
it's like abnormal like maybe it's like
a rookie of the year situation
like i don't know what the [ __ ] going
on down there like maybe there's
something actually
happening down there that i don't know
about but it's a very very tight
situation which i like yeah but i also
think that
there's a physical aspect of it and
there might be an emotional law where
you're just so hyped up to finally be in
or like you care about her so much that
when you go in you're just like oh my
god it only took me three seconds
i couldn't i just couldn't last but i
didn't first
that's the only thing oh first time i
wasn't like i'm in love with this trick
but that happens though at least in my
experience it does happen where like
there's an emotional aspect of
like the hype of i [ __ ] like her so
much i just made me not in three seconds
yeah
so then i don't know if it's physically
better because it might just be like
psychological i just remember noticing
because i had
just been with another person and then i
was with my one
my now wife and i was like whoa yeah
like that's all i just remember that was
bomb ass [ __ ] it was bombs [ __ ] bomb
even without her moving
she just laid there she was just like
the way just the shape of it that's
it awesome it was it was pretty cool
yeah today's video is brought to you by
upstart upstart can help a lot of people
out out there you know these days
if you've already had those credit cards
with like the zero percent apr and now
it shoots up because sometimes it only
lasts for six months to a year
you might have a ton of credit cards out
there they're like oh no i'm getting
crushed by all these aprs and i can't
manage all these credit cards
well you can use upstart to help lower
your monthly payments by consolidating
all of that
into one payment at one interest rate
you know
apr also sounds like annual punishment
rate oh it does because the the rates
that some of these credit card companies
charge you is like
20 something percent 16 like that's a
lot i don't know
how i was able to ever get my freaking
payments down
because that was so much money and if
you're just paying the minimums you're
gonna be
paying for a lifetime long time so it's
awesome that there's companies like
upstart out there it's awesome that
upstart exists
because it only takes five minutes to
see if you qualify for the loan or not
and they use other criteria beyond your
credit score
to judge if you can qualify for the loan
or not such as your employment
your education and other things that
make you a whole human being
and boom when you get this you could get
it like the next business day
and it's up to 50 000 and that's my
favorite part because a lot of times
when you're in a pinch
you can't wait like a week or you can't
wait a month for
underwriting for like a normal loan to
happen it does take time to get your
money sometimes
or even if you're trying to apply for a
credit card it takes two weeks for them
to send it to you
so if you're in a pinch and you need it
tomorrow upstart is a good way
to get some money to help you out
whatever your situation is so go check
it out
upstart.com off the record to see if
upstart can help lower your monthly rate
or give you money that you might need to
help benefit your life but your actual
loan amount will be determined by your
credit score
and your income and also the other
information that you do
put in on your application so go check
it out go to upstart.com
off the record i don't even know if like
that's biologically true if like diff
if women their canal is different
well i know eagles can kegels can
actually do that there's obviously a
difference because people can get this
um it's not surgery anymore you can get
treatment done to get it tighter
yeah and you can get treatment done to
actually get more lubrication so i know
that there is a difference
but a lot of people have been like to be
honest with you
they can't tell you can't really tell
the difference like if there's a
difference in sexual performance it
usually is associated with oral or
flexibility or how much they're into it
but like the actual because you know
what penis is there's
a big difference yeah you know
nice so you could feel you could could
you spot your husband's penis out of a
bunch of the other ones like as soon as
it goes down yes
i could you could feel the difference i
could yeah
yeah i might ask my wife this question i
think then the difference is there but
it's slight
i'd say it's not like you know like i've
seen pornos where the guy looks
like he has a [ __ ] you know third leg
or something
and i'm like how do you have a baseball
bat yeah you know and that's a huge
difference
but i don't know if girls have that
drastic of a difference
yeah it's like a guy has like i think
it's like a baseball bat
the way that you put it was like you've
been through some [ __ ] he's like he's
like reminiscing about it like it was
like a war story i even saw one in real
life
man at the spa at the korean spa
yeah all right you know how everyone's
naked yeah yeah and i saw this guy
he was uh sitting on like you know
there's a laying
area and then there's like a small
little like i guess
what do you call like a curb that you
can kind of sit on right so he was kind
of squatting his dick was
his balls were [ __ ] touching the
ground and his dick dude
oh wow the whole thing i was like good
for him how close is he to the ground
though he's squatting like over like
like very close to the ground no i mean
like imagine like yeah i mean imagine
you're just on a
squat but you're kind of sitting on like
a small little thing right
and it was just laying there and i was
like
wow mine doesn't do that well he could
be a shower that could be maximum that
could be the end but though some
people's showing it's like
it's still bigger than my girlfriend
yeah yeah but you go to like
the spa right they give you a hand towel
and there's this guy who's holding your
hand down he was covering it but it
wasn't covering that much
and you're just like [ __ ] i need to put
on the [ __ ] stethoscope
breathe get the blood pressure it's
crazy
you're like whoa it's like wow it must
be nice huh
is that like your new research right now
you're trying to see if sizes are
different for women i just came off of a
show that i worked on this week
and um every it was about it's called
x-rated
so the premise is you would come on and
we would issue a survey to 10 of your
exes and ask them 21 questions about
your sexual performance
and your intimate performance oh sure
and then you would get like the
cumulative rating from all it's like a
yelp review for sex yeah
it's so invasive yeah so you got to call
your exes and let them hey i'm on this
show
but if you don't have ten x's yeah
exactly it's not just exes it's uh
one-night stands it's something that you
just made out with
you know the person friend zoned you can
you tell a couple of them to go [ __ ]
themselves for me
left on good terms and stuff right
they're just going to destroy your
damage dude
damn that must be crazy i bet people get
shredded on there it was
do you remember though like i don't
remember most of my ex's sex performance
well i have one ex i know that just
[ __ ] hates me still
probably you think they would spite they
would spite rate you they would
no matter what yeah do you think it's
like it's like is the [ __ ] bomb
the pussy's not bomb
envelope that is wrong and everyone in
the eye is like
that's a good show that's a good show
because it's like you rated yourself a
ten
your ex has said a two and it's like
that
how do they react what do they do well
people nervously laugh some people are
just like
but then people go the thing that's so
important you have to
uh survey multiple because if it's just
one person they discredit that person
yeah so you got to remind them to be
like hey this is not just that one x
for me it's like mine what the [ __ ] is
agreed for me
i got the best [ __ ] dick hundred
thousand percent and then like that is
not the best dick and i'm like mario i'm
like
[Laughter]
i want to see that dude oh but we got to
do it like judge judy style
we have a
so wait what's your role in it you i was
an expert on it
so i just came out to like help somebody
who
ego was deflated and it's like hey man
we figured out that you need some help
in this area yeah
i mean you can improve i mean we i tried
sometimes it just wasn't possible
really yeah what's the most common one
that you saw that people
like you got a weak dick like what was
their most common
foreplay was the weakest score for
people you know what it is because
people's definition of foreplay is so
different
from personal preference some people
were like i'm [ __ ] incredible at
foreplay and someone was like you spat
in my ear that's not
different flavors not my top three moves
not my top three moves you gave me a
noogie dude what the [ __ ]
well spitting in the mouth is very
trendy right now too
i could see that more than spitting in
the ears the ear is weird though that's
like
is that is that done like centrally or
is that done aggressively
like what is spitting in the mouth is it
like is it a degrading thing it's like
[ __ ] you yeah
yeah or is it like
like recipient area yeah just for
anything in general i got that
talking i got bad at it do you like ear
stuff no
no my my lady does she doesn't do
anything with your shirt i think it's
hard dude
yeah is it harder like no it's like it's
like physically hard
part of the normal yeah you want to
touch it i do
there's this side oh my gosh this one is
like now you got it oh my god
now you're gonna grow it you're going to
grow a little dumpling
you're welcome i was unexpectedly hard
is it like cartilage now yeah i don't
know what it is that's clay
if you get punched does it hurt it does
or hurt more
no actually not but when i do this like
i just grind on people like that that's
not very nice that kind of hurts me dude
it does right yes we do but you look
like man you look like you're ready for
war though
no i'm not that's the thing that's the
sad part
when i worked at giant rockets and this
ear was all [ __ ] up but this one was
normal
i would people would ask me how i fought
and i didn't want to like i'll be like
uh
i was born with it i would just tell
them i was born with it and then they'd
be kind of uncomfortable and they'd be
like oh
you don't like to show off huh why
wouldn't you say i fought
well because it's like a whole thing you
know like talk about it and it's like
why
you don't like talking about it you
don't like getting clients no
this is before i was even coaching
people well i get it like you have to
repeat the same story over
there there's a weird thing that happens
when people will find out they want to
fight you
fighters are so humble dude no it's not
even that it's not even that it's just
like
people are just [ __ ] annoying that's
what it is
people are annoying about it was one guy
i was at the beach and this guy was like
hey man what's up and i was like
hey and he goes what's your no we're
under johnny rocket's clothes yeah
always
and he goes he goes what's your style
man and i'm like what
it's like what's what kind of a [ __ ]
question she said 80s new wave
yeah [ __ ] see that's what i wasn't
prepared for that stuff
oh okay okay but next time people always
go on this like weird tirade of like oh
yeah i used to fight too man back in the
day
you know and they're just like you have
to listen to their story [ __ ] off
because they just want that bro
connection yeah and it's like that's
cool man
you know but a lot of the times it's
they're they're kind of [ __ ]
sometimes some of the times but it's a
great cheat
it's a great hack because if i'm at a
bar i'm [ __ ] drinking i'm drunk off
my ass i want to pick a fight with
somebody i'm like
nope
yeah it looks good looks good okay looks
good
tango okay come here let me show you
yeah whoa no no
no no no no no no no we know either get
cauliflower ears
or get get arms like bart yeah have you
seen his butt though this dude got a
foul you got an incredible butt
you got a dumper on this one you got a
dunk what happened would you find a guy
with a big old fat
only if i get it if i win
can you imagine some guy step up to you
he goes
i'm fighting for that ass i get your ass
hey we're playing for pinks dude
and you're like that's a good
stipulation
i'll sign up for that yeah yeah let the
best man win
now that you're training though do you
tell people that you're a fighter uh
well i used to i stopped fighting you
you also helped to normalize you know
what i had that same problem
with what i do for a living that i used
to have a different answer because every
time i say
that i'm a sexologist it was always this
big thing yeah and people get weird
about it too
but then i realized i'm helping to
normalize the field and then so the next
person that they meet
who's into the sex education field
they're like oh i know somebody who i
met like that
that's an interesting take on it i never
thought of it that way because i get a
little bit
where people are like hey man you lift
and then i used to say oh i love lifting
or whatever and they're like oh i used
to bench like 500 in high school
and then i said yeah kind of the same
type of annoying people i'm like oh no
not really
and i'm like oh okay all right you don't
lift my nah
and then that way so i avoid the whole
and confusing
you look at this guy bro i'm born that
way you live
but i'm not trying to avoid those weird
conversations where like i don't
care about like if you're here to put
like spectrum
internet in my house i don't need to
know that but you're not trying to
collect gym members
you guys are the worst business people i
don't know it's just that's way better
small talk than the weather
that's way more interesting that's true
i ran like [ __ ] on her wives or
something you know like yeah
boy
[Laughter]
sucks to have people come up to you and
go man you must lift a lot huh
really it must be hell you talk about
the thing that you love all day long
that seems like it's pretty rad damn now
that you're explained that way i'm like
i'm a [ __ ]
idiot that's why they're horrible
businessmen yeah
yeah i guess so huh yeah hey i have a
gym no it never happens
[Laughter]
that's a sign i coach people how to
fight but i don't fight
it doesn't happen and she's like yeah
i'm a comedian and everyone's like
oh okay all right i guess i could have
been
in his business but now i was looking
for a gym
can i ask you to wait real quick social
security numbers
how high are they now because you just
had a baby are they in the nines yet
oh i don't know the answer's question
you don't know your child's social media
why would i memorize the
social security i'll buy that they go up
by the years they have to right are they
wait
what dude i thought you're a canadian oh
[ __ ]
she doesn't have the same numbers as
well no i do i i'm immigrated
i can really yes please still pay me
yeah we're gonna check okay i'm gonna
call a guy
are you uh do you have a green card yes
oh then you get a social security number
after you do that i didn't know that
just like you will you let me know
because i'm genuinely curious okay
[Music]
you